are you following what they're saying
with you know biden's warning about
cyber attacks from russia are you
following that story
yeah um how much credibility do you give
to that that could happen
oh i would say very credible and i'm
just hoping the government
is astute enough to
have plans i remember i joined wall
street almost 60 years ago and one of
the first companies i visited was a
company called bemis company
okay in minneapolis
and they told me they had just completed
a government contract
you be news to you to bury a couple
hundred million shrouds along the
eastern seaboard because they felt in
the event of a nuclear attack we
wouldn't have the time to bury everybody
so we had shrouds buried along the
eastern seaboard to cover the bodies in
the streets
so you know the government's always
thinking for us you know hopefully they
know what's best ah they know what's
best they know what's best for you i see
the smile on your face of course i mean
you're talking to the guy who escaped
that to be here so i can make a decision
for myself if i screw up go be it but no
this is what biden said he said on march
21st the more putin's back is against
the wall
the greater the severity of the tactics
he may employ
one of the tools he most likely to use
in my view in our view is cyber attacks
uh the magnitude of russia's cyber
capacity is fairly consequential and
it's coming he continued so
you know does anybody does anybody
really know
what that would look like is anybody
talking about what that was they shut
down the power grids and stuff like that
yeah and that's where they can be the
most and and the financial aid they did
to the colonial pipeline yeah you know
where they had gas lines for a while
look this is a different form of war and
hopefully it's cyber and not nuclear
you know
you read my mind much more dangerous
but that's a good way to to sow the
seeds of societal unrest in a in an
economy that that's plagued by
inequality is you turn the lights out we
have to decide whether we're a
capitalist nation or a socialist nation
i think one of the biggest threats this
country has is from what i read 30
percent of the young people think
socialism is referred to capitalism
scary so scary did you see the chart
about the support for union since 1965.
did you see that chart that was shared
okay tyler do you have that or no
if you have that if you can pull that up
make it okay so this is from our uh uh
go go a little lower so he knows who
it's from that's from robert reich i'm
sure which you appreciate robert wright
yeah robert
socialist another associate absolutely
public support for unions is at a
50-year high this is a big deal you see
approval rating how high it is 68 last
time we were there was 1965 a year
before you got
with uh goldman uh is this
for for the average person i was like
what's the big deal unions are good
because they protect the employee
what does this mean to the average
person that's reading this i'm not an
anti-union but i would basically just
say it's very clear that the
power is shifting from capital to labor
right now
and that's one of the reasons i'd have a
conservative view about the market
you know um
i'm not anti-union uh
basically um
this is just a fact of life did the
pendulum swing too far in terms of
well incomplete is a big issue i'm
talking about ceo pay versus the people
who are working for the companies yeah
uh it has but you know
warren buffett says that uh
you know they ought to name these uh
consultants ratchet ratchet and ratchet
because they just come and they bless
what the boards want to do
uh i think it is a big problem you know
i own stock in a
uh company um
that the ceo has made a shitload of
money a huge huge amount of money and
the stock is lower than it was a decade
ago
and uh this is wrong
and you know i just don't have the time
to tilt the windmills so i
keep the position small or i just move
on
and sell well at the end of the day you
get what you pay for and you can pay
people to be productive
you can but i think that
business is getting paid more than they
uh produced and you quote like kyle icon
he's a big soapbox on that and he's not
wrong
but
business is getting paid more than they
produce
in some instances yes in some instances
they get paid less
you know uh
like i said one of my heroes was henry
singleton of teledyne never made more
than a million dollars a year uh running
the company
and he was absolutely brilliant in
everything he did
you know he basically did 130
acquisitions intelligently
he uh basically bought stocks in other
companies intelligently
he uh managed his own capital structure
he brought back 90 of his stock before
dying
uh very intelligently he made the
investors a shitload of money never
never got paid a lot of money and he
made the money but he owned 20 of the
company
and he was totally aligned with the
shareholders
i think that this income disparity is a
very long-term issue and it has to be
dealt with through education
amen
amen well you know uh basically uh
you gotta create economic opportunity
for people and you got to give them the
tools to be competitive
and i think education is the best way to
do it if you enjoyed this short clip
click over here to watch another short
clip and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]